it was energy that first brought the
founding member states together 64 years
after the advent of the Coal and Steel
Community the EU is ready to take
another leap forward with 28 member
states each with their own regulations
and energy mixes more often than not
European citizens and consumers get the
short end of a liberalised energy market
to remedy their semi p.s have taken a
first step towards setting up a European
energy union in a committee vote today I
think we stepped up and showed that this
extra committee is capable of working
together across political parties in
order to get things done the main points
of the new energy framework our energy
security the EU imports fifty three
percent of its energy its biggest
provider is Russia with all the
political entanglements and
uncertainties that come with that
decarbonisation of the economy with the
Paris conference just around the corner
the EU wants to have a greater share of
renewables in its energy mix shabana
poder venir de semana para la fievre
climatic a donkey foucault museo civico
raja de la pelona sarasota cur diesel e
equal / continually ejecta Lefevre are
too clever next the report will be
presented in plenary in December
my TV